[Music]
hey everyone welcome to our installment
of Harry Potter theory in this video
were going to be discussing Suites of
the Wizarding World
or more specifically Bertie Botts every
flavor beans Bertie Botts beans are
basically the Wizarding equivalent of
jelly beans but come in a much wider
variety of flavors some delicious and
some disgusting
the bean flavors of course covered the
basics like chocolate and green apple
but they also cover some questionable
flavors like envelope glue and dirty
sock here's what Dumbledore has to say
on the matter ah Bertie Botts every
flavour beans I was most unfortunate in
my youth to come across a vomit flavored
one and since then I'm afraid I've lost
my liking for them but I think I could
be safe with a nice toffee
um alas earwax
Ron Weasley would go on to include Georg
swears he got a bogey flavored one once
the true kicker with Bertie Botts beans
is that you never really know what
flavour you're going to get placing your
tastebuds in a veritable state of the
confusion and trepidation if you've been
fortunate enough to visit the Wizarding
World of Harry Potter in Orlando or
Universal Studios then you may have been
able to pick up the pack of Bertie Botts
beans or maybe you pick some up in the
shambles in York but if you've never had
the opportunity to try them then you
truly have no idea what your taste buds
are missing though the real-life Bertie
Botts beans were only manufactured in 25
flavors the Wizarding World had many
more in fact they had every flavor but
here are the ones that we know about in
this video we'll be quickly going over
every known flavor of Bertie Botts beans
almond Apple aubergine bacon baked bean
banana belly button lint
blackberry beef casserole blueberry
blueberry pie bogey booyah base broccoli
welcome buttered popcorn cauliflower
cheese cherry chicken chili powder
chocolate chocolate cake cinnamon
coconut coffee cranberry cream puff
curry dirt dirty sock dog food
earthworm earwax declare envelope glue
farm dirt beat fish fried egg great
Bocelli grapefruit grass gravy green
apple ham honey
horseradish ketchup lemon liver liver
and tripe lobster marmalade marshmallow
mashed potatoes mint mushroom mussel
mustard olive onion orange of cooked
cabbage peach pear pepper peppermint
phlegm pink grapefruit pizza prawn
pumpkin roast beef what an egg salmon
sardine sausage sherry soap spaghetti
spinach sprout steak strawberry
strawberry and peanut butter ice cream
sugar violet sulfur toast
toffee toffee apple toffee pudding
tomato troll bogey tutti frutti vanilla
ice cream vomit and watermelon and that
concludes the list of all known flavors
of Bertie Botts beans which your
favorites least favorites let us know
down in the comment section below
until next time you're a wizard Harry
[Music]
you